we don't have a trivia question today
chris i'll go ahead and let you have the
first pick because i'm confident i'm
very confident in my i want to run here
i i i beat you barely on monday
destroyed you yesterday i'm going for
three in a row yeah yeah kiss my butt
and kiss my butt okay you didn't win
either day all right so here we go
all right uh i i think you know
uh suspect number one for me and the guy
that doesn't get credit or the hell with
the stats this is calais campbell colise
campbell is going to be my number one
guy there i mean class campbell's a hall
of fame defensive tackle we don't you
know i know people know him but he's not
talked about as one of the best
defensive players or defense alignment
in football and he has been for i don't
know 10 years now he's been in that
conversation you know leica michael
bennett can play defense to end can play
defensive tackle one of the most giant
humans i've ever seen you know and again
what you talk about with these type of
guys disruption you know and then a game
plan effect they have right and coleas
campbell's a guy that you know you got a
double team or you run away from them or
you know certain plays aren't going to
work when you run them his way uh so to
me that's the guy that jumps out to me
more than than the rest right now
you know i am stunned i am surprised i
handed it to you i gift wrapped it one
of your favorite guys in the league is
the clear cut i love how you like to do
this you love to give me the number one
pick i pick it i pick a good pick and
then you crap on it go ahead who is it
i'm not crapping on your pick i'm saying
that you avoid it and you ignore
something's wrong with you between
putting aaron rodgers at number two on
your quarterback list three but notho
beckham jr number six number three
number three even worse number three not
number two
putting otto beckham jr number six on
your receivers and having the prime
opportunity to sing the praises of the
guy who is indeed so freaking awesome
but doesn't get the opportunity to prove
that he's so freaking awesome because of
the offense that he's in deshawn
watson's statistics do not demonstrate
his greatness because he's middle of the
pack in all of the major statistics
because number one they don't throw the
ball as much as other teams do and
number two he's running for his life
before he throws the ball most of the
time he doesn't have the help around him
especially now that deandre hopkins is
gone and even with hopkins he didn't
have the help that he needed he doesn't
have the blocking doesn't have the
running game 16th in attempts 13th in
yards 11th in touchdowns 11th in passer
rating he was sixth in completion
percentage though at 70 percent plus
sean watson
is every bit as good as the very best
quarterbacks and you have him in your
top five think of how much higher you'd
have him if he was on a team that
actually used him to his full capacity
chris well yeah i you know i get it
you're right but like this is not within
the spirit of the rule or the draft here
i mean come on the stats don't tell the
story he is better than his stats but we
he's better than he talks now we know
but we a lot of people know that a lot
of people know that is what i'm saying
that's everybody knows that he's like
one of the five ten best players in
football i i don't i don't agree with it
i don't think i think that i think the
stats keep a lot of people from feeling
that he's one of the top five guys
really really stretching the the rules
of this draft there
it fits right into the wheelhouse
right into the wheelhouse right right i
know michael ben and desean watson
they're both household names right all
right all right so wait wait was it
confined to defensive players no when
did i miss that text message yesterday
no all right then shut up and make it
you missed you missed the point of the
draft apparently that's what happened
here all right my next guy
i'm going with the honey badger in
kansas city all right i am you know the
stats nothing you're going to see there
is going to be like eye-popping it
doesn't matter about that and then you
know i don't even know what his pff
grades are and things like that but the
value he has to a football team first
off off the field you know we heard all
that stuff last year right he was the
leader of the kansas city chiefs like
the second week he was there then he is
like a swiss army knife and the things
he can do in the secondary and that's
his true value i mean he can play
linebacker he can play free safety he
can play corner he can play nickel
corner you know he really does
everything and they they put him in some
of the toughest situations that safety
can put to where i'm sure sometimes his
grades for certain games might not look
good but you know they ask him to cover
like you know a george kittle man-to-man
in big situations where like a lot of
safeties wouldn't be asked to do that in
football so yeah there's four he's gonna
get beat by some guys here and there but
he's asked to do things that most normal
safeties in football don't do so i think
between that and then of course his open
field tackling and energy he brings to
the field on a sunday uh one of my
favorite guys to watch and i think he
fits the mold of what we're talking
about better than desean watson
now look i'm not going to crap on that
pick because i like tyron matthew that's
a great pick you took one of my picks
maybe i should have just gone good since
you wouldn't have taken deshaun watson
anyway no i wouldn't have bagged him
until round three but tyron matthew and
it is the tangibles and the intangibles
and the fact that he is that weapon that
you just put in the defense of secondary
and let him do whatever needs to be done
and he is a great leader i remember when
they did the all or nothing series on
amazon with the cardinals and there was
a scene where he gives a speech in the
meeting room and it's powerful he's a
great leader and he's one of the reasons
why the the chiefs were able to hold it
together was a great signing last year
sneaky great signing when they grabbed
tyron matthew and a very valuable piece
of that team and any team should want a
tyrant matthew all right
i'm gonna go
with a guy that we've mentioned a few
times over the past few days
uh
who currently is unemployed
and is waiting for the right opportunity
janaevian clowney the king of the up the
play staff there you go
his stats never do well one of the
reasons his stats never really really
tell the story is he doesn't play enough
to have stats but even when he does play
on a consistent basis it's not like he
has a four sack game but he creates
havoc on every single play and he's a
guy that there is a perception he hasn't
lived up to his potential but he does
have the ability to take over a game and
allow his teammates to be the ones to
get the tackles and the sacks and the
forced bumbles and the interceptions
yeah great pick by you great pick by you
i mean yeah he is he's this is this is
one of the originators of the f the play
up or you know one of the title holders
certainly i mean like i said michael
bennett is the originator but yeah
there's been a lot of years where you
know i i i get done with the season and
go oh i think you're dave van clotte was
one of the you know four or five best
defensive players in football you know
you look at his stats and you go oh he
has five sacks and people just don't
believe that but you know you made all
the points you're right he is a
nightmare and i mean he linebacker
defense end can line up a defensive
tackle walks around the line of
scrimmage with the snap you know i've
never seen a guy as strong as he is for
like you know i know he's like 260
something pounds but he had plays with
the power of like a 310 pound man the
way he controls people so uh i'm with
you there i like that um man i have so
many guys to pick from here
i don't know where to go here i really
don't but i think i'm gonna go i'm gonna
get one big guy in the in the mix here
all right and that to me is dj reader
all right dj reader got a big contract
from the cincinnati bengals i got to
give one big you know
big big guy some love here nose tackle
the last few years for the houston
texans and to me you know there's a lot
of guys these interior defensive linemen
who are underappreciated but he's one of
the best in the business as far as pure
nose tackle i mean he's just an
unmovable force he can take on double
teams i mean you watch film of him
sometimes and there's two and three guys
on him he's just raw
and he holds his ground and you're like
damn there's like 980 pounds trying to
push this guy and they haven't moved him
an inch so you know those guys always
are underappreciated they cause their
havoc in their own way not by busting in
the
you know through the line of scrimmage
but more of making a mosh pit and not
letting an offensive line get any
movement that way uh they're very
undervalued and that's why he got paid
big bucks by the bengals
and i understand that this was inspired
by defensive players but there are
players at every position who
other than kicker and punter whose stats
don't necessarily tell the story
although there are some punters i think
where the stats wouldn't tell the story
because a high gross average doesn't
mean you're a great punter
where you put the ball and how many you
put inside the 20 right yeah your gross
average could be not that good if you're
punting from the 40 and you're you're
pinning it inside the the five yard line
every time
but i didn't think of that until just
now so the punters didn't get included
in this sorry punters um
i'm going to go with and you're going to
complain about this but i'm going to go
are you going to go are you going to go
with patrick mahomes here or who are we
going to go there funny
anything else actually devonta adams was
my next piece oh you're funny
i i a guy who has not had stats yet and
probably won't have very many stats this
year given all the weapons that are
around him and that are competing for
the football but how about cowboys tight
end blake jarwin okay 31 catches 365
yards three touchdowns last year kind of
a forgotten man but a guy they really
like now last year you know with jason
witten around that kind of affected his
output but between amari cooper and cd
lamb and ezekiel elliot i you know
jarwin
may not get a chance to truly flourish
the way that he could but he's going to
be a reliable piece of that puzzle one
of the reasons why the cowboys didn't
bat an eye about jason witten walking
away and uh i think a guy to watch even
though yes he probably won't have big
numbers again this year no probably not
not eye-popping not going to be like
travis kelsey george kittle those type
of numbers you're right but mike you
know i don't know if i would have picked
him from the draft but i think he's like
a guy that's like an up-and-comer like
you know
i would say watch out he could jump on
the scene as a lot of people going damn
this like darwin guy is really damn good
i mean the talent is real you're right
about that so i'm not mad at you for
that one i think he is better than
people realize and i think he's gonna
have a big a much bigger stake in that
offense this year than than normal um
what do you want to talk about some of
the guys we didn't put on like real
quickly who else do you guys well i
thought of julian edelman i mean i did i
mean julian edelman you know his stats
are good right i mean they're not
eye-popping you know i'm still a little
mad at julian edelman for his ped use
and that's ultimately why i didn't pick
him but damn you know i don't think
stats tell the whole story about him and
the attention he has created through the
years with his great underneath route
running you know the trick plays you
know whether it's the all the touchdown
passes and things like that he's just
got great value there off the field too
you know blocks in the run game he's
just a complete football player you know
used to be amazing on special teams as
well so he was one that really jumped
out to me
marvin jones jr the highest receiver is
a guy had on the list 779 receiving
yards that does not tell the story of
how good he is and i had a couple of
other defensive players vaidavea the
buccaneers defensive tackle he had only
three sacks last season uh but a guy who
was very disruptive and jeffrey simmons
yeah rookie with the titans last year he
only played in nine games but he was
tremendous but the numbers wouldn't tell
you
the defensive guys get screwed over they
really do a lot of times but yeah i you
know jimmy ward either with the free
safety for the san francisco 49ers he
was on the list for me marlon humphrey
you know i just don't know if peop i
view marlon humphrey is certainly a top
five corner i would say he's the second
third best corner in the game i don't
know if he's viewed that way you know
and of course the akeem hicks william
jackson of the cincinnati bangles
another top five corner in my opinion uh
that nobody knows about so yeah this is
a fun exercise i like this it makes you
think about some guys you wouldn't
normally think about or talk about here
on the show
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports